date
foreign
house of public prosecutors
prosecutors of the republic of north
carolina the ombudsman members of the
government of the republic of north
missouri
the governor of the national bank of the
republic of north missouri and the chief
of the general staff of the army of the
republic of northern estonia
the president of the macedonian academy
of sciences and arts the head of the
macedonian orthodox church archbishop of
warcraft and macedonia
of the islamic religious community of
the republic of north missouri
roman catholic bishop skopje and
parkhill bishop of the catholic church
in the republic of north macedonia
the president of the church offices
superintendent of the evangelical
methodist church in the republic of
northwestern the president of the jewish
community in the republic of north
missouri
the state attorney of the republic of
north macedonia and has a foreign
diplomatic and consular missions
accredited in the republic of north
macedonia allow me to greet
the guests on your and my personal
behalf on behalf of the assembly of the
republic of north macedonia and on my
own behalf it is my honor and pleasure
to welcome among us the president of the
european commission
ms russell
distinguished miss ursula from their
line i invite you to take the floor and
address the assembly of the republic of
north missouri
thank you dear
president pendarovsky
dear speaker
jaffery
honourable members of the parliament
prime minister kobachevsky
president of the supreme court ademi
it's a pleasure
to be here
and i thank you very much for the
invitation
the honor
to speak to you here in this honorable
parliament
and to this plenary
i wanted to be here today with you
so that i may speak to you directly
so that you may hear from me
how europe is waiting for you
waiting
and hoping
that we you will take yet another step
towards the union
your country
is a candidate
to become a member of the european union
since 2005
many of you here
and many many more who are absent
have worked so
hard
to become a member of the european union
and only four years later in 2008
the european
commission recommended
that we open
accession negotiations with you
since then
we have consistently stood by your side
and now finally
we could be on the threshold
of a decisive step forward
i am here today
because i believe
that this is the moment for you
to move ahead
with north macedonia
as a full fledged member
you have shown
history
north macedonia has shown
that it is a reliable
a real added value to the alliance
and i know
that the same will happen
when you become a member of the european
union
i know this because you have already
demonstrated
a vital capacity
to change your society for the better
your efforts to strengthen the rule of
law to fight against corruption
are commendable
you have established a strong record
of human rights
you have a free media
you have a vibrant civil society
you are a successful model
of a diverse
multi-ethnic
society
forged in the historic auric framework
agreement
you chose a path
of peace
rather than conflict
and this was the path of peace
shown by the late president
boris trejkowski
he said
that he
and i said
intended to be the president of all
citizens
regardless
of the ethnic or religious background
regardless of their political standing
and he added
that he would
to undermine
the stability
of the country
honorable members
many of you will
understandably
be frustrated
that your country has not yet begun
accession negotiations
and let me tell you i am too
the commission has been recommending
the opening
for the last 15 years
and you will be
understandably
frustrated
that the opening of negotiations with
the european union
did not immediately follow the prosper
agreement
this was
bitter
but you never gave up
and we together
never gave up
together we followed our dream
of one european union
and together we will turn this dream
into a reality
we must all now turn our gaze forward
we must grasp the opportunity that lies
before
us to launch accession negotiations
and work together on the path
takes into the european union
we can do
this soon as next week
by taking the first step
of the revised french proposal
you are all very aware of the revised
proposal
it protects your interests
assured
that the commission
that has always stood by yourself
in this country
continues to stay by your side
and will be there for you
tomorrow
and all the many days after
we are convinced that this is a historic
importance
but the decision
is yours to take
and yours only
ultimately this is about the path
you chose
and you have chosen before
with the orat framework
with presbyter
with the building of a vibrant society
and democracy
should you decide to endorse the revised
french proposal
a political intergovernmental conference
will be held within the next few days
we the commission
will then start immediately
to process
the screening of screening the yaki
and this is the first step in the
negotiation process
and we will then be glad to welcome
your negotiating team to brussels and
send our negotiating team
to your capital
to start working together
i thank you for this democratic behavior
dear macedonians
i have listened
carefully
to the concerns expressed
regarding the macedonian language
and identity
there can be no doubt
that the macedonian language is your
language
[Applause]
[Music]
and i'm happy to repeat it there can be
no doubt
there can be no doubt
that the macedonian language is your
language and we fully respect that
and that's why
the revised proposal refers to the
macedonian language
without
qualification by the european union
[Applause]
the proposal
also respects your national identity
the principle of self-identification
is so important for each one of us
you can count on me
as president of the european commission
to ensure
that the accession process
will strictly abide by european
principles and european standards
yours
the eu's motto
united in diversity
you have shown commitment
to the rights of all communities
and these are values that we all share
amending your constitution to advance
fundamental rights further
will reinforce your commitment to these
values
and
then this will automatically complete
the opening phase of the negotiations
it will trigger another
intergovernmental
conference without any further decision
good neighborly relations and regional
cooperation
a part of the dna of european
integration
and these are also essential elements in
the enlargement process
as well as the stabilization and
association process
for all enlargement countries
let me reassure you
bilateral issues
such as the interpretation of history
are not conditions of the accession
negotiations
[Applause]
some say it would be better to wait for
a better deal than the one presented by
france
it is of course your right to do so
but please consider
how hard we all have tried
to get here through success
presidencies
germany
portugal slovenia and now france
and i encourage you
to seize this opportunity
empower itself
by being in the negotiation process
rather than outside of it
and benefits will accrue
most important door for them
i have children
i have a granddaughter
many of you have children
some of you have grandchildren
and all of us together
i think we share the same dream
that one day
our children and our grandchildren
they are all part
of the same european union
that's what we want
and this is the future you are deciding
about here
today
tomorrow and the next days
honorable members
we live in very difficult times
as the covet 19 pandemic is stretching
into the third year
its catastrophic effects have continued
to impact people's lives
and livelihoods
russia's brutal war in ukraine
has unleashed a devastating humanitarian
and global food crisis
energy prices are skyrocketing
in addition we have to fight
the escalating climate crisis
these are all daunting challenges
that we must face
but we can master them
and we will master them
together
as strong democracies
as one union
your country has risen to the occasion
you stand steadfast with the union
you are a true
and reliable partner
and i thank you for that from the bottom
of my heart
you have shown your determination to the
eu values
you deserve to move forward on the path
to membership
your decisive step forward
is now
yours to take
and i would like to end
with another quote from president
trejkowski
i cite
it's his words i want to cite
i consider two things on a daily basis
what is right to do
and what is wrong to do
according to my conscience
i am trying to abide by the right thing
my vision is peace
my vision is prosperity
end of quote
and i fervently hope
that you too will do the
same do the right thing
for the peace and prosperity of
knowledge
remember your opinion
the future of your country is in the
european union and europe
is not complete without north macedonia
blagodaram
[Applause]
i conclude that the 80th session of the
republic of north macedonia
has been completed